you
welcome to Abbott's web series at Abbott
we know that a healthier Hospital begins
with a healthier laboratory because labs
performing at their best deliver results
that provide better patient outcomes and
improve healthcare value
Abbott can help you redefine performance
with personalized and innovative
solutions that leverage our resourceful
advocates experts to help you achieve
your goals and deliver critical
performance metrics harmonized systems
innovative instruments informatics and
automation solutions that streamline
your lab operations and intelligent
insights professional services to help
unlock the value of your data across
your network and discover greater
operational productivity we hope you
find Abbott's web series a unique and
vital resource in helping you achieve
measurably better healthcare performance
[Music]
hello and welcome to our web series I am
Jennifer Holland Steen senior director
of research and clinical systems at Evan
today my colleagues and I are excited to
share with you some first look
perspectives of Abbott's newest clinical
chemistry and immunoassay systems the
ulema DCI series joining me is dr. Jose
Santiago Global Marketing Manager for
the Elend ECI series assays at Abbott
and Brittany Dressler global marketing
manager for the Olinda CI series systems
together we're going to explore how
three institutions have begun to improve
their productivity and flexibility with
the alehna DCI series Jennifer thank you
it's great to be here I think the
illinit ECI series is an excellent
example of Abbott pioneering innovations
and delivering personalized solutions to
help our customers achieve measurably
better healthcare performance and today
Brittany and I are looking forward to
discussing this next generation of
harmonized
thanks Jose yes I'm also looking forward
to discussing the most important
features of the illinit ECI series
systems as you may know abot salinities
CI series received european c ii marking
late last year and we're thrilled to
have recently received US fda clearance
the illinit ECI series is now available
in Europe Asia and Latin America that's
great news in fact the Elend EC and the
Allende eye that make up the Olinda CI
series are just two of the seven systems
of the Olinda family the portfolio
provides a unified experience across key
laboratory disciplines including
clinical chemistry immunoassay
hematology transfusion molecular point
of care and informatics yes Jennifer
built from the ground up these
innovative systems incorporate
attributes our customers told us were
most important in the systems they use
every day the illinit e systems have
been built around the user first they
deliver uniformity helping standardize
operations so labs can optimize their
resources and maintain high levels of
service they also provide flexibility
with a scaleable and integrated design
and multiple track connectivity options
for today's high performing labs they
also deliver increased operational
productivity providing greater
throughput and capacity in a more
compact footprint helping to address
limited space and increasing demand and
finally with era proof design elements
and proven technology these systems
provide confidence so that labs can
continue to deliver the highest quality
results in a timely manner Thank You
Brittany I think we're off to a great
start understanding a Linna DEA's
potential to transform the lab and are
ready to take our first look at how the
Olinda CI series reliability and
performance was demonstrated in a core
lab in Toronto Canada and I FCC 2017 in
Athens
we heard dr. Paul Yip speak as professor
at the University Health Network and
University of Toronto Canada he was one
of the first Olinda C clinical chemistry
users he shared his initial experience
using the Olinda C
system and the data set gathered on a
pre-production system before doctor yet
began his study we installed the Elana
DC system in his lab we were able to
connect the illinit EC next to his
architect clinical chemistry system from
Abbott as the Elina DC is just half the
size of the architect after SCI
qualification it only took two rounds of
performance verification and fairly
quick training before dr. Yip could
study the performance of the old NDC
across multiple assays this underscores
the simplicity of the new technology
user interface dr. he performed
potentiometric photometric methods using
commercial control materials and
clinical specimens initially he wanted
to evaluate precision on this new
illinit EC system the first he conducted
a five-day precision study that used
third-party control materials and tested
the sodium potassium chloride total
carbon dioxide and magnesium research
used reagents let's see what he found
out
I'm showing you data from the five-day
precision study so this included both
the bio rat and the techno path controls
they were run for five days there was a
break in between those five days and
this included three different levels and
here are the range of the abnormal low
up to the abnormal high and this was
done for two runs per day separated by
two hours and there were two replicates
for per run so each of these represents
an N of 20 and you can see that there
was excellent precision for these these
assays that we have done in the
precision study and when you compare
them to the goal based on the biological
variation you could see that the sodium
was comparable the potassium was was
excellent far below the goal chloride
was comparable now co2 of course is a
very tricky analyte and this of course
does not meet the ideal goal but this is
very comparable to what what we have in
the laboratory and probably comparable
to what you have in yours
so three four percent is quite typical
for co2 and then magnesium this is a
very challenging assay you can see that
that is quite comparable to the goal
based on biological variation as well
next doctor yet wanted to explore the
reliability of the system by evaluating
the instrument over a four-week period
dr. Yip tested more than 2,000 clinical
specimens for calcium creatinine glucose
and magnesium assays as well as the
electrolyte sodium potassium and
chloride over a four-week period and we
did a total of 2,000 52 specimens and in
this particular study we ran about 150
patient samples per day and each patient
sample was tested in three replicates
alright so that gave about 43,000
replicates and 98.7 percent of which met
the expected precision and in terms of
overall reliability during that time
there were no service calls so this
shows that ahead and that
reliability in that period I'd say
overall that is a very favorable
performance of the illinit ec system
that's great Jose it really speaks well
to the reliability of the Olinda si
system that all assays met expected
performance during the testing period we
also have immunoassay data from dr. Karl
Lochner
he too was one of the first users to
experience the powerful capabilities of
Ana Lindy system Britney tell us about
dr. lock nurse data I would be happy to
Jennifer based in Mainz Germany the
central laboratory for the University
Medical Center Mainz runs approximately
6 million immuno chemistry tests per
year there dr. Lochner wanted to find
out how the illinit e.i system compared
to his existing architect immunoassay
platform both in his lab and across five
others in the world first he evaluated
precision on key infectious disease
assays this was performed mostly with
control material but I was later show
you correlations to the architect
systems this was done on real-life
samples from our clinical Center there
are two exceptions we don't have enough
htlv positives and mines and also
syphilis is relatively rare in our hands
but we have sufficient hepatitis and HIV
patients in our Center what you see here
is the total within day in precision of
the different assays which is comparable
to the performance of the architect
system dr. Lochner also talks about the
linearity of TSH conducted in Tokyo and
Torino you can see from the graphs where
Tokyo data are shown on the left and
Torino data are shown on the right there
is good linearity performance across the
measuring range he then evaluated as a
sensitivity by assessing limits of blank
detection and quantitation TSH limit of
blank was done in in Sydney and we see
that all samples limit of blank the
claim is 0.02 6 100 percent of samples
in this Center were within the claim
limit of detection again 100% within the
claim Jennifer would also like to point
out about dr. lock nurse presentation is
that the correlation between assays on
the illinit II eye system and the
architect eye mm is excellent as seen on
the troponin example this really speaks
to the commute ability of results
between the architect and the elena di
system dr. Lochner also had even more
positive comments on the illinit e
system from his laboratory technicians
what I did here I just list the three
things which were mentioned by our
technicians most consistently one is
that the reagents can be loaded while
the instrument is running daily
maintenance has been simplified wash
solutions are ready to use that was one
of the major improvements compared to
the architect handling and calibrators
and controls can be stored on board so
these are the three things most
consistently mentioned by our
technicians if you go ahead and ask them
as we heard from the previous two
speakers the Olinda CI series not only
demonstrates high quality analytical
performance but also helps improve
operational productivity with innovative
features like continuous reagent and
sample loading and onboard Cal's and
controls it's impressive that the Olinda
CI series delivers all this in a more
compact footprint yes Jennifer the
intelligent design of the illinit ECI
series reduces the footprint of the
system while increasing the throughput
this makes it one of the most efficient
systems providing more tests per square
meter than other systems on the market
today we've learned a lot about what the
Olinda immunoassay and clinical
chemistry systems can do in core labs
from its reliability and delivering high
quality precise results to its
productivity and ease of use but what
about its flexibility the ability to
scale with ease so that a lab can expand
and adapt to their changing needs
well vo path a leading private
laboratory in France
and one of the first laboratories
globally to have used an integrated
illinit ECI series system can give us
some insights into illinit ease
flexibility serving 2,000 patients 24
hours a day
bo path completes an average 26,000
tests daily and Bo path has big
initiatives to grow to serve 5,000
patients per day all while investing in
technologies that will help them towards
continuous productivity improvements and
uninterrupted service to understand how
Bo path plans to do this let's hear from
their CTO mr. Jerome moto and learn why
they chose the Elend ECI series systems
for their laboratory we are happy to to
increase our productivity with an
ethnicity who is a compact system and we
have a reduction of the size for the
automatic Eliza and it's very important
because our platform are the same space
and we must increase our activity in the
future we increase of the number of bond
tests and throughput on the ATTC by your
eleventh Poisson and adding GE by 40%
combined with existing systems and it's
a flexibility for our organization so
with improved operational productivity
the ulema DCI series systems make it
possible for Bo path to achieve quality
results in less time right and talking
about quality let's take a look at their
clinical chemistry precision evaluation
Bo path achieved excellent single digit
CVS for the clinical chemistry assays
evaluated looking at the amino acid
position of the elyda TI vo path also so
fantastic results that allow for high
confidence in the performance of the
system
TSH for instance had CDs of 1.8 to 2.5
across all levels not only was the
imposition low but all the methods
evaluated show good correlation to their
counterparts on the archit
systems
so together the assay performance offers
quality results and the Elend ECI series
system enables bio path the flexibility
to grow so they can continue to provide
a high level of service to their
patients Jose and Brittany it's been
really great to hear some insights from
some of the first Olinda CI series users
still there's a lot left to be discussed
and we have some questions from our
online audience our first audience
member wants to know how equivalent are
the results between the architect and
the illinit ii systems Brittany we heard
this addressed in some of dr. hip and
dr. Lach nurse presentations but I'd
like to elaborate on it Abbott has
incorporated some of the same proven
technologies currently used in our
architect systems to maintain the same
high quality assay results the reagents
used in the illinit EC Andale inna di
systems are the same high performing
reagents illinit e also uses the same
signal detection technology as our
architect platforms to help assure
commute ability of high quality results
across systems
additionally the illinit ECI series
assays have been harmonized with the
clinical laboratory and standards
institute guidance to ensure clear
performance parameter definitions Jose
what do you think are some of the most
appreciated aspects of the architect
technology that have been translated to
a Lindy the architect platform
technology you'll see in the new illinit
ECI series systems includes electrolytes
performed on our integrated chip
technology sample interference indices
smart wash and flex rate technology clot
and bubble detection as well as amino
acid Kenna flex technology that together
provides the proven level of performance
we've come to expect Thank You Jose
Brittany our next question comes from an
audience member that states she has a
lot of turnover in her lab and wants to
know if the Olinda systems will be easy
to use Jennifer that is a great question
illinit e is the only family of systems
that offers a common and intuitive user
interface across all systems so that
users can easily transition from one
system to another
throughout the lab with minimal training
the illinit ii systems will allow your
staff more walk away time so they can
spend their time and other value-added
tasks there's an inherent accessibility
built into illinit ii that should
empower users to be confident in their
skills and their labs output it sounds
like the Olinda systems are making good
on Abbott's promised to help labs
redefine their performance and address
their greatest challenges today's
exclusive first look provided a glimpse
of how the Olinda systems can deliver
uniformity flexibility operational
productivity and competence but how
exactly does the Olinda system deliver
on its promise to simplify diagnostic
testing while ensuring speed accuracy
and performance don't miss the next
segment in our discussion where we learn
all about the features and functions of
the Olinda CI series thank you for
joining us today Brittany and Jose Thank
You Jennifer it was my pleasure thank
you mine as well and if you have more
questions about what we learned today or
in any future presentation in our series
just email us at web series at Abbott
comm we look forward to hearing from you
thank you for watching Abbott's web
series we hope you found it to be a
unique and vital resource in helping you
learn how to achieve measurably better
healthcare performance be sure to join
us for the next Abbott web series as you
continue your quest to transform your
laboratory and institution to be its
healthiest
you
you